[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo und geräts die mittelland ich
glaube niemand würde bestreiten dass die
schweiz eines der außergewöhnlichsten
schlimmsten und erstaunlichsten länder
der welt ist obwohl es zwischen hohen
bergen eingebettet und mit ausnahme der
legendären käsefondue bergwerke ohne
nennenswerte natürliche ressourcen was
sich die schweizerische
eidgenossenschaft die konfiguration
weniger zu einem der reichsten staaten
der erde entwickelt sie ist auf einem
land voller kuriositäten zum beispiel
hat sich von dort aus die
milchschokolade über den ganzen planeten
verbreitet für viele ein ist süchtig
machen das genussmittel für liebhaber
echter dunkler schokolade jedoch eines
kredit das ähnlich gespalten ist die
welt auch was die schweizer
exportschlager kurt felix und paola oder
ist recht klein bobo angeht und falls
euch diese namen nichts sagen kann ich
euch dafür nur beneiden bewahrt euch
eure geschmackliche unversehrtheit und
gut bitte nicht danach aber die schweiz
hat der welt auch viel positives
gebracht es ist jener ort an dem die
besten uhren der welt hergestellt werden
wird aber so ist das nun mal und es ist
ein land mit vier verschiedenen
ansprachen und das mit weniger als neun
millionen einwohnern
damit hört das skurrile aber noch lange
nicht auf wenn wir sprechen von einem
staat der so eigenartig ist dass er noch
nicht mal einen hock stadtrat und 9
ihr müsst jetzt nicht ausgelebt und
beschreiben nennen bei der gründung des
schweizerischen bundesstaates gab ist
eine heiße kontroverse darüber ob die
schweiz überhaupt eine hawks haben
sollte und in welchem kanton die sind
liegen solle
als kompromiss böte mahlberg als
designierten sitz des bundesrates also
der schweizer regierung gab aber nicht
offiziell also de jure 2
dass dies so war es für die hauptstadt
sein würde und dass ein solches alpen
paradies mit einem mehr als
beneidenswerten natur auch nur eines der
frühesten und demokratischsten länder
sowie eines der am wenigsten gruppen in
der welt ist gehört auf dieser welt ja
eigentlich auch ins kuriositätenkabinett
natürlich können das tägliche käsefondue
und viel gute schokolade wunder bewirken
aber so groß
nicht nur wahrheit ist dass es andere
etwas anderem liegt als an der show qi
und dem früh gestellt vor das
einzigartige politisches system der
eidgenossen
[Musik]
als system das von vielen analysten der
modernen politik als nichts geringeres
als eine wahr gewordene utopie
bezeichnet wird etwas so selten dass und
großartiges das ist ein komplettes
visual politik video verdient hat indem
ihr euch genau erklären die ist denn
eigentlich funktioniert seid ihr bereits
dann mal los das politische system der
schweiz basiert auf drei grundprinzipien
der zentralisierung föderalismus und
direkte demokratie
wir sprechen von einem land in dem die
bürger seit mehr als einem jahrhundert
direkt über die wichtigsten fragen der
staatspolitik bescheiden denn im
gegensatz zu allen anderen staaten
europas sind welches die obrigkeit war
von der die macht ausgeht ist die
schweiz politische und traditionell
wollen unten nach oben gebaut das
fundament bildet dabei stand die
gemeindeversammlung sie ist der ursprung
lokaler gesetze regeln und werte der
schweiz die schweizer bürger kommen hier
zusammen handeln und legen so den
grundstein für ihr zusammenleben
die meisten kommunen mit mehr als 10.000
einwohnern verfügt zwar über ein
gemeindeparlament in zwei kantonen
glarus und appenzell innerrhoden er
lässt jedoch das volk alle kantonalen
gesetze in eine versammlung aller bürger
der sogenannten landsgemeinde wir
sprechen hier über gemeinden mit bis zu
40.000 einwohnern die per handzeichen
direkt abstimmen können man sieht also
dass die demokratische partizipation in
der schweiz sehr vielfältig und fast
immer so direkt wie möglich gestaltet
ist natürlich hat ist mehr als nur ein
paar jahre gedauert bis sich ein solches
modell so gut einspielen konnte die
eidgenossenschaft wie wir sie heute
kennen begabt 1848 gestalt anzunehmen
als sie sich von einer einfachen
konfiguration und weniger kantone zu
einem modernen staat mit einer
zentralregierung entwickelte will auch
mit stark dezentralisierten macht man
könnte sagen dass die kantone so etwas
wie die deutschen bundesländer sind
jedoch über eine viel größere politische
finanzielle und administrative autonomie
verfügen
[Musik]
insgesamt ist in der schweiz 26 kantone
mit mehr als 2000 gemeinden
jeder kanton hat seine eigene
legislative exekutive und judikative
sowie eine kantonsverfassung alle
staatlichen aufgaben und kompetenzen die
nicht von der bundesverfassung den bund
zugewiesen sind gehören in die kompetenz
der kantone darunter das schul und
gesundheitswesen die kulturpolitik die
kommunale infrastruktur und die polizei
und sie können selbstständig entscheiden
die hohe steuersätze sie dafür heben die
tat ohne gewähren ihrerseits ihren
gemeinden eine gewisse autonomie um zum
beispiel die grundschulen und weitere
lokale dienstleistungen die
straßenreinigung wird doch sicherheit zu
verwalten
infolgedessen ist der zentralstaat
musste aufgaben zuständig die das land
als ganzes betreffen die außenpolitik
die streitkräfte wurde die
leistungsfähige infrastruktur des
gesamten staates ist alles andere liegt
in der verantwortung der
gebietskörperschaften kantone und
gemeinden wirklich gelebte subsidiarität
also nach der jede aufgabe ist so nah
wie möglich am bürger gelöst und
bestimmt werden sollte und höhere
instanz nur genau das regel was die
kleineren einheiten alleine nicht
schaffen würden
gilt das nicht sehr sinnvoll und
attraktiv dann hört jetzt gut so denn es
gibt noch viel mehr attraktive dinge
über dieses ungewöhnliche politische
system zu erfahren in dem präsidenten
nur ein jahr lang an der macht sind und
die minister aus einem breiten spektrum
der politischen parteien kommt nicht nur
aus einer bestimmten regierungskoalition
und wie könnte man besser beginnen als
mit einem blick auf das berühmte
schweizer system der direkten demokratie
[Musik]
direkte demokratie eine verwirklichte
utopie eine kleine frage zu ob wenn ich
verstehen würde euch die ideal die
perfekte demokratie vorzustellen sie
würde diese aussehen ich bin sicher dass
für viele von euch die antwort in einem
modell liegt bei denen die bürger nicht
einfach nur alle vier jahre wählen gehen
und ihre vertreter dann tun lassen
können was sie wollen nun die schweiz
wird oft als das land des ewigen
wahlkampfs bezeichnet es ist ziemlich
wahrscheinlich dass ihr bei einer reise
durch das alpenland wahlplakate sehen
werdet die um eine stimme für oder gegen
die eine oder andere angelegenheit
werden die schweizer stimmen nämlich
drei bis vier mal pro jahr wird
bestimmte nationale politische themen
hinzu kommen alle vier jahre die
parlamentswahlen die kantone an wahlen
und die gemeindewahlen die mancherorts
sogar populärer sind als die der höheren
ebenen was im weltweiten vergleich eine
absolute anomalie darstellt
die schweizer können auch
volksinitiativen und volksabstimmungen
lancieren volksinitiativen sind zum
beispiel ein instrument mit dem ein
bürger einen gesetzentwurf vorschlagen
kann über den im parlament abgestimmt
werden muss wenn man mehr als 100.000
unterschriften dafür zusammenbekommt
und obwohl es diese möglichkeit auch in
vielen anderen demokratien gibt ist die
wahrheit dass solche initiativen in den
meisten ländern so gut wie nie bis in
die parlamente vordringen meist weil die
politiker dieser länder
diese hohe hürden für ihren erfolg
gerichtet haben stark und unrealistische
anforderungen kompetenz überschneidungen
mit anderen vorschriften und allgemein
eine ablehnende politische kultur welche
oft ängste vor der ungefilterten stimme
des volkes führt ganz anders die schweiz
ist das mutterland des modernen
referendum falls euch also noch jemand
fragt wer hat's erfunden jetzt kennt ihr
die antwort volksabstimmungen content
der schweiz nämlich nicht nur von der
regierung sondern auch von den bürgern
selbst vorgeschlagen werden diese
referenten werden mit dem ziel
organisiert eine regelung von
erheblicher gesellschaftlicher bedeutung
zu verabschieden oder eine bereits vom
parlament verabschiedete regelung zu
kippen 50.000 unterschriften sind dazu
erforderlich hat so viele die bei einer
volksinitiative
und hier kommt die politische kultur und
die mobilisierung der titel gesellschaft
ins spiel
in der schweiz gibt ist
interessensgruppen mit unterschiedlichen
agenten die in relativ kurzer zeit die
benötigte anzahl von unterschriften
sammeln können was für einen einzelnen
bürger natürlich sehr kompliziert werden
darüber hinaus kann die bundesverfassung
ohne eine abstimmung durch die bürger
selbst überhaupt nicht geändert werden
jede änderung in welchem abschnitt muss
pro volk direkt gebilligt werden
ebenso wie jeder vorschlag für den
beitritt des landes zu bestimmten
internationalen abkommen man spricht
hier von den sogenannten obligatorischen
referenten
und eine vorstellung davon zu geben was
ist alles bedeutet in einem gründlichen
jahre 2021 finden 45 abstimmungen statt
1 am 17 märz ein weiterer am 30 juni
eine weitere am 26 september und lässt
am 28 november
tja da fragt man sich doch ernsthaft wo
finden die schweizer eigentlich bei so
viel power kam von abstimmen noch
genügend zeit für ein gemütliches fest
und hinzu kommt dass es für die annahme
oder ablehnung einer volksinitiative
oder eines obligatorischen referendum es
nicht nur notwendig ist dass die
mehrheit der bürger der ganzen schweiz
dafür oder dagegen stimmt sondern auch
die mehrheit der stände und damit sind
die kantone gemeint einen kanton steht
in der abstimmung der stände immer so
wie die mehrheit seiner eigenen bürger
abgestimmt hatte sind also mehr als 50
prozent der wähler eines kantons gegen
das referendum stimmt auch der kanton
dagegen sind mehr als die hälfte dafür
gilt auch der kanton dafür
und um alles noch komplizierter zu
machen haben nicht alle 26 kantone ist
gleichgewicht bei der abstimmung soll
sich haben je eine volle und sechs je
eine halbe stunde in der praxis
scheitert alle referendum also wenn die
mehrheit der wähler in 12 kantonen
dagegen ist uns dabei der abstimmung der
stände die bevölkerungszahl nicht
berücksichtigt wird könnte es sein dass
eine gruppe von dünn besiedelten könnten
eine initiative kippen könnte
selbst wenn dort noch eine kleine
minderheit der weder wohnt klingt
ungefähr gut das alles ist im grunde
eigentlich nur ins system dagegen
gerichtet dass mit der absicht
geschaffen wurde die stabilität der
ganzen eidgenossenschaft zu stärken so
dass dichter besiedelten regionen nicht
die gesamte entscheidungsmacht dazu
fällt keine abstimmung der stände sind
übrigens nicht statt beim zweiten
volksabstimmung der fakultativen diese
betreffen nicht die verfassung sondern
einfache bundesgesetze und bundes
beschlüsse die recht also die mehrheit
des ganzen volkes
auch in den einzelnen kantonen ist das
referendumsrecht umfassend ausgebaut
heißt noch weitergehend als auf
eidgenössischer ebene wobei es liegen
kann dann ganz anders gestaltet sein
kann
die kantone sind auch hierbei sehr
autark und ihr haltet euch fest jetzt
kommt nämlich der knüller auf kantonaler
ebene geht es nämlich noch das zehn ins
referendum
dabei haben die bürger bei
ungewöhnlichen ausgaben des staates die
möglichkeit diese durch ein referendum
einfach zu verbieten
in den kantonen appenzell ausserrhoden
und schwupps ist dies sogar
obligatorisch somit ist die schweiz das
einzige land in dem die ausgabenpolitik
des staates durch förmliche
volksentscheide kontrolliert wird
erzählt mir also nicht dass ihr von
diesem system nicht beeindruckt und auch
überrascht sein und vielleicht auch
ziemlich neu nicht aber natürlich muss
man bedenken dass das modell der
direkten demokratie etwas komplexer ist
als einfach nur zur wahlurne zu gehen
und über die eine oder andere
initiativen abzustimmen um bei einer
dieser abstimmung erfolg zu haben
braucht es zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen und die mittel um die
vorhandenen gegengewichte zu überwinden
aber jetzt werdet ihr euch vielleicht
fragen
bei so viel direkter demokratie was
bleibt da eigentlich für die
parlamentarier übrig was machen die da
für ihre diäten wie sieht ihre
gesetzgebende gewalt aus und wie setzen
sie in der schweiz gesetze überhaupt
passiert das alles etwa auch so
ungewöhnlich wie das was wir bisher
gesehen haben
und das schauen wir uns jetzt mal die
überraschendste legislative der welt als
erstes muss man wissen dass die
schweizer legislative auf bundesebene
aus zwei kammern besteht im nationalrat
und der ständerat dem nationalrat
besteht aus 200 abgeordneten welche
durch die bürger in kantonalen
wahlkreisen gewählt werden und zwar nach
dem verhältniswahlrecht was bedeutet
dass die bevölkerungsreichsten kanton
mehr sie zu haben die obere kammer der
ständerat setzt sich aus 46 vertretern
der schweizer kantone zusammen 40
kantone wählen dabei die 24 je einen
vertreter
mit anderen worten im ständerat findet
das mehrheitswahlrecht anwendung die
bevölkerungszahl der kantone ist für die
sitzverteilung also irrelevant wieder
soll ein breiter konsens ermöglicht
werden indem verhindert wird dass die
bevölkerungsreichste stadt ohne alle
anderen über stimmen beide kammern
bilden die sogenannte bundesversammlung
und manchmal so ganz bestimmte
abstimmungen dass sie sich gemeinsam was
dann die vereinigte bundesversammlung
ist aber was ist ein moment denn die
kuriositäten ende nicht tatsache ist
dass die schweiz eines der am stärksten
frequentierten politischen systeme der
welt werfen wir zb einen blick auf die
zusammensetzung des nationalrats denn
das ist in der tat der schlüssel zum
verständnis dessen was bei euch jetzt
erzielen werden wie ihr sehen könnt
zeichnet sich das schweizer parlament
ist eine starke reduzierung oder je nach
sichtweise durch große qualität aus den
nationalrat in drei bis vier große
parteien in vergleichbarer größe sowie
etwa sieben weitere kleinere vertreten
auf den ersten blick würde dieses
politischen szenarios sicherlich auf
alle situationen der ohne regier barkeit
hinweisen ehrlich albtraum muss ist doch
sein eine einigung zwischen so vielen
verschiedenen parteien zu erzielen
aber das ist in der schweiz nicht der
fall denn eigentlich ist in der
schweizer politik genauso wie beim
gemütlichen käsefondue die grundlage
immer dass es enge zusammensein der
konsens das mehrparteiensystem und die
partizipation jedes einzelnen
wenn jeder so sein brot abwechselnd ins
verstecken und sagt werden können ohne
dass man sich mit den vorgaben ins
gehege kommt oder gar sticht dazu sind
jedoch genauer regeln und viel rücksicht
erforderlich ist ein vorgeschmack darauf
gegeben der präsident des nationalrats
darf nur ein jahr im amt bleiben dann
wird wieder eine andere person zum
präsidenten des parlaments gewählt und
ja diese person kommt normalerweise von
einer anderen partei als ihre fordere
man könnte sagen dass der geist der
helvetischen politik von der idee
beseelt ist dass die konzentration von
macht in wenigen händen um jeden preis
daneben werden muss und eine der
zauberformel welche die eidgenossen
gefunden haben war die begrenzung der
mandate auf ein jahr und wenn system das
die abstimmung verschiedenster parteien
geradezu erzwingt dass ich das alles
etwas seltsam an nun lasst es uns
herausfinden wenn wir uns ansehen wie
die regierung des bundes der sogenannte
bundesrat eigentlich funktioniert
[Musik]
aber bevor wir dazu kommen lassen nicht
noch eine liste sache über die
legislative erkläre funktionen also was
sie eigentlich macht denn natürlich hat
in einem so dezentralisierten land wie
der schweiz auch das nationale parlament
nur begrenzte aufgaben so ist es vor
allem mit der verabschiedung von
gesetzen und verordnungen des staates
befasst zu haben
diese nicht in die zahlreichen
kompetenzen der kantone eingreifen
es ist zuständig für die vorbereitung
von verfassungsänderungen
staatsverträgen die dann wie bereits
erwähnt obligatorischen referenten
unterworfen werden müssen
aber die beiden vielleicht die
wichtigsten funktionen die die
legislative hat sind zum einen die
ernennung des generalstaatsanwalts der
anders als in den meisten ländern nicht
von der regierung ernannt sondern von
allen parteien gewählt wird und dann das
wichtigste von allem die wahl damit ihr
des bundesrates und seine präsidentin
als bundesrat wird in der schweiz die
zentrale bundesregierung bezeichnet denn
ja auch das schweizer system ist ein
parlamentarisches system so dass der
bundespräsident nicht direkt vom volk
sondern von den abgeordneten gewählt
wird ja soweit eigentlich nichts
umwerfen das so jetzt kommt aber der
nächste helvetische knüller der
möglicherweise haben wir es hier mit dem
seltsamsten regierungssystem der welt zu
tun und gleichzeitig mit einem der
leistungsfähigsten ein regierungssystem
dass in fast jedem anderen land sicher
scheitern würde das aber in der schweiz
stabilität einigkeit bei kultureller
vielfalt und ja auch fortschritt
wohlstand und freiheit gebracht hat also
seid ihr gespannt darauf wie dieses
außergewöhnliche regierungssystem
aussieht dann ist das ist sofort einen
blick drauf werfen
[Musik]
die seltsamste regierung der welt
ich werde euch jetzt etwas erzählen was
viel selbst auf vorkommen mag im jahr
2019 hieß der bundespräsident uhr lima
jahr 2020 weiß simonetta sommaruga und
im jahr 2021 ist es gibt ja das ist
richtig aber keine panik wir sprechen
hier nicht von einer regierungskrise
epischen ausmaßes zur schweizer
bundespräsidentin ist es ganz normal nur
ein jahr lang im amt zu sein vom ersten
januar bis zum 31 dezember den
sogenannten präsentieren ja anfang
dezember eines jeden jahres tritt also
die vereinigte bundesversammlung
zusammen um den präsidenten für das neue
präsidiale jahr zu wählen damit
ziemlicher sicherheit von einer anderen
partei kommen wird als im vorjahr
außerdem kann ich dieser person für das
folgende jahr wiedergewählt werden es
muss eine andere sein allerdings muss
die gewählte person eines der sieben
mitglieder des bundesrates seien die
alle vier jahre gewählt und dabei auch
wieder gewählt werden können falls er
kommen noch nicht explodiert ist machen
wir jetzt weiter denn es gibt noch mehr
der bundesrat wird durch das sogenannte
direktor system reagiert das bedeutet
dass alle sieben mitglieder der
regierung genau den gleichen status in
bezug auf entscheidungsgewalt und rechte
innerhalb der regierung haben niemand
ist auf der leiter höher als ein anderer
ja das stimmt die schweiz ist derzeit
ist einzige land auf der welt mit einer
regierung die im grunde ein
kollegialorgan ist der präsident leitet
lediglich die sitzung und und vertritt
die regierung in ihren auswärtigen
beziehungen
aber das ist alles mehr macht hat er
nicht außerdem wird die regierung seit
vielen jahren von vier verschiedenen
parteien gebildet und dabei wird ein
konsens aller schlüssel angewandt claire
von den schweizer liebevoll als
zauberformel bezeichnet wird
[Musik]
mit dem schlüssel zwei plus zwei plus
zwei plus eins werden die ministerposten
auf die vier dateien mit den meisten
stimmen verteilt und erinnert ihr euch
was ich vorhin über die parlamentarische
park mit die rung erzählt habe dass sie
eigentlich überall sonst in einem
regierungschaos münden würde nun nicht
in der schweiz denn wer hat die
zauberformel erfunden richtig
[Musik]
und um die sache noch komplizierter zu
machen werden bei der bildung des
bundesrates nicht nur die politischen
parteien berücksichtigt sondern auch die
kulturelle diversität aus diesem grund
kommt von den sieben ratsmitgliedern
vier aus dem deutschsprachigen teil 2
aus dem französischsprachigen teil und
eines aus dem italienischen teil auf
diese weise entspricht die
zusammensetzung der regierung der
kulturellen verteilung der schweizer
bevölkerung so dass sich niemand
beschweren kann
und tatsache ist dass all das was ihr
gerade über den bundesrat gelernt habt
am ende einen sehr praktischen effekt
hat konsens sagen sie einfach dass er es
nicht erleben werden dass sich ein
mitglied der schweizer regierung bei
einer von der mehrheit des bundesrats
getroffenen entscheidung wer stellt wie
es in vielen anderen ländern der fall
wäre die idee dahinter ist dass alle
sieben mitglieder alle gemeinsamen
entscheidungen als ihre eigenen
verteidigen müssen auch wenn ihnen
manche davon persönlich nicht unbedingt
gefallen
manchmal gibt eben danach manchmal der
andere und sich die schweizer regierung
aber auf dieser welt wirkt das schon von
einem anderen planeten die quintessenz
des ganzen meine freunde ist jedoch dass
das politische system der schweiz aus
vielen gründen vielleicht eines der
besten ist es verbindet die direkte
demokratie mit der dezentralisierung dem
föderalismus verkörpert ist und es
garantiert auch den zusammenhalt in
einer kulturell sehr vielfältigen
gesellschaft und das alles bei
gleichzeitiger förderung des
mehrparteiensystems und der
konsenspolitik eigentlich also ein
kinderspiel halten wir jedoch mal einen
moment inne
denn die alles im leben gibt es einige
herausforderungen denen sich auch dieses
system stellen muss insbesondere was die
zukunft betrifft herausforderungen
welche es noch nicht gab als dieses
system entworfen und eingeführt wurde
wollte wissen was genau ich damit meine
nun aufgepasst
[Musik]
nichts ist völlig perfekt das politische
system der schweiz ist sehr alt und
funktioniert immer noch sehr gut aber
als es geschaffen wurde dadurch die
gesellschaft und das land nicht genau so
geschaffen wie sie es heute sind eines
der probleme ist sozusagen das ist in
der schweiz im grunde eine art föderales
wertung gibt so kann zum beispiel ein
vom nationalrat verabschiedetes gesetz
vom ständerat der die kantone unabhängig
von der demographischen verteilung
vertritt geblockt werden und das kann
auch bei volksabstimmungen passieren wie
schon gesagt haben kann zum beispiel
eine verfassungsreform durch die
volksabstimmung angenommen und durch die
abstimmung der stände das haus der
kantone gekippt werden und denke jetzt
nicht dass dies schwierig und die
ausnahme wäre die 30 kleineren kantonen
in denen nur 11 prozent der wähler leben
haben quasi eine sperrminorität
also selbst wenn die anderen 80 prozent
der wähler einstimmig so etwas stimmen
würden die kleineren kontrolle mit nur
11 prozent der wählerschaft die
entscheidung drehen wir sprechen hier
von einem ungleichgewicht das im laufe
der zeit immer weiter gewachsen ist und
dass heute sehr stark ausgeprägt scheint
aber neben dem praktischen föderalen
veto gibt es noch ein anderes problem
das ebenfalls sehr besorgniserregend ist
[Musik]
in den letzten 50 jahren hat die schweiz
eine vielzahl von einwanderern
aufgenommen so dass heute mehr als 20
prozent der wohnbevölkerung der schweiz
ausländer sind knapp die hälfte davon
sind eingewandert deutsche franzosen
oder italiener und mehr als eine halbe
million ausländer haben eine in der
schweiz fremder muttersprache etwa
400.000 sind moslems nun warum ist das
wichtig also die herausforderungen oder
das problem ist dass nur schweizer
bürger in der schweizer bundespolitik
partizipieren können und ebenso sieht es
in den allermeisten kantonen und
gemeinden aus außerdem ist es sehr
schwierig die schweizer
staatsangehörigkeit zu erwerben kurz
gesagt es gibt einen nicht unbedeutenden
und stetig wachsenden prozentsatz der
bevölkerung der politischen leben
praktisch ausgeschlossen ist nicht
wählen und auch nicht kandidieren wir
gehen auch sei jedem fall ist das
politische system der schweiz ihr sehen
könnt alles andere als gewöhnlich
es ist eine kombination aus kuriositäten
eigenheiten und balance die es
zweifelsohne zu einem einzigartigen
system machen mit vielen vorteilen und
ja auch mit ein paar nachteilen aber was
denkt ihr nach dem jetzt alles gehört
habt über das politische system der
schweiz wäre in eurem land in eurer
gesellschaft ein solches system auch
möglich was würde ihnen im weg stehen
und was müssen wir ändern damit es
überhaupt eingeführt werden könnte
immerhin sind wir auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat und ihr lust
auf leckeres ok käsefondue und mehr
demokratie bekommen habt weil sie
ergebnis mit unlike teils mit euren
freunden und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]